[Musique]
ici c'est tout un gymnase qui s'est
transformée en atelier semi industrielle
de couture à la rivière saint-louis
le département a réalisé en partenariat
avec le syndicat de la couture
réunionnaise ce vaste atelier de
fabrication de masque en tissu
nous avons ici environ 180 200 personnes
qui se sont déplacées spontanément ça
leur laisse la possibilité précisément
de montrer club et les gens du rsa sont
également solidaires des couturiers et
des couturières tous bénéficiaires du
revenu de solidarité active
ces volontaires en participant à cette
mission d'intérêt général bénéficieront
de l'aide financière l'insertion une
aide départementale cumulable avec le
rsa comprise entre 456 et 792 euros par
pôle emploi
et comme sur la table on m'a proposé
tout y était bénéfique pour moi je ne
savais pas à repasser ni poudre ou en
plus on apprend des choses et puis voici
nouvelle aventure humaine et
financièrement va être contente aussi
avec le défraiement qui m'aide un peu 15
chaînes de production sont établis
comprenant chacune 12 postes de travail
au total ce sont près de 200 couturier
qui s'organise dans cette production de
masque en tissu dont le prototype a été
réalisé par l'atelier départemental défi
la première chose qu'on va leur demander
c'est de faire ni noir ensuite on va
glisser les élastiques
donc ça c'est un autre poste en ferme on
on attache les élastiques être le match
le masque c'est la 3e troisième poste
ensuite on retourne tout ça c'est un
quatrième poste on repasse c'est encore
un autre poste en
le plie en deux et en sueur pic c'est un
poste de plus et ensuite on fait un pli
le masque pour que ça ressemble au
masque qui sera apporté un poste de plus
et la dernière le dernier poste c'est
une surpiqûre de chaque côté 17
couturière confirmé du syndicat de la
couture réunionnaise encadre et forme
ses volontaires la plupart des personnes
n'avaient jamais touché une machine donc
l'armée ou moi même je suis étonné en
trois jours ce sont des personnes qui
ont eu la volonté de décès à ces masques
là est en fait si elles ont une petite
passion va ça va ça va plus rapidement
par cet atelier réalisera 70 mille
masques par semaine soit près de 300
mille masques pour un mois de production
une production rendue possible grâce au
vote en commission permanente le 29
avril dernier du plan masque
l'objectif étant
protéger les agents du département ainsi
que les publics vulnérables en leur
proposant des masques tout en favorisant
des dispositifs d'insertion
nous avons près de 6000 agents qui pour
équiper en matériels notamment masques
mais aussi pour les travailleurs sociaux
les travailleurs à domicile pour nos
personnes âgées pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
nous avons près de 35000 personnes âgées
ou en situation de handicap le
département accompagne à travers la paix
en échec santé et bien valeur donné des
masques tissu pour se protéger et on en
donnera aussi au travail à domicile et
après bien sûr les associations
nous avons des partenaires comme les
ccas les associations qui travaillent en
lien avec nos le 10 des partenaires
institutionnels qui pourront
s'approvisionner auprès du département
le plan basque prévoit de soutenir une
trentaine d'initiatives associatives
pour la production de masques en tissu
la collectivité compte ainsi réaliser
600 mille masques par ces ateliers
d'insertion au profit de la population
réunionnaise
[Musique]